the Joe Rogan experience listen man I've
been a fan of yours for a long time I
bought true story and I have you Wow
yeah I bought that book way back in the
day man I was living in New York it was
a great book that's a very underrated
book on standby [ __ ] [ __ ] yeah it's a
novel yeah no it's a novelization of my
early life very accurate though like
it's you could feel like you live the
life and you know though your names were
hilarious of the characters each other
no I worked probably harder on that than
almost anything I've ever done I would
never really yeah I would never write
another no but well just to make every
sentence every paragraph funny or
telling no extra words to me that's the
kind of what you write that I funny I
started it in the early 80s when I was
still almost living it and I would get
busy and put it aside not to look at it
for years and then I did a is my old
life in 1985 in December I went down to
see want Anejo Mexico to do the
memorable TV movie TV movie there's a
phrase that date ship the memorable TV
movie Club Med I think we all remember
it no we don't Linda Hamilton was the
star I think I do remember it I hope you
don't I remember Linda Hamilton okay yes
right you know I'm I'm picturing it it
was a TV movie and we stayed at the Club
Med I was in you know you it was kind of
a low-budget thing as far as the people
in the cast and crew went because we
stayed at the Club Med which was not a
Club Med it's not a luxury hotel you
know what Club Med's are you you give up
your money you pay everything in beads
but you don't really need money and the
rule is for people who just you're gonna
enjoy the outside that's why you're in
Mexico so the room is monastic right
there's no TV because you're out all day
you know you're just gonna be in the
waves and then you
[ __ ] can go to sleep and whatever so I
had a lot of free time because I wasn't
in the shot every day but I was in
Mexico eventually I got [ __ ] cabin
fever down there you know I couldn't
wait to get home but as they're a long
time and had nothing to do and I wrote a
lot of the novel there and put it away
again and then I was in a real career
slump in the early 90s I had finished
with acting mostly I didn't want to do
that anymore I'd done a few sitcoms and
I didn't want to be the office creep
forever and so I was just like nowhere
and that's when I finished it and also
that's like the year I did cocaine which
I probably would not have finished it
without that it was only one year it was
one year I was never meant to do cocaine
when everyone was doing it I never
wanted it you know me I'm a pothead like
you I I it's not my drug but you know if
you really insist you can get in you can
get into any drug and I and I just
happened to be at this point in my life
where I was vulnerable to any I had
nothing to do all day I wasn't working
so and it helps you write it helped
productivity it's a Productivity drive
was never a drug that I liked because I
wasn't social on it but I could I use to
like to have sex on it well most men did
not I love that and and right but I
didn't want to talk some people I get at
that guy I don't know is never that guy
who did coke and talk a blue streak no
but but it helped me you know
concentrate and organize and that kind
of stuff and you know and then I was
probably smoking pot - I was smoking
cigarettes it was not a healthy year
that was not a healthy year I remember
you know you because cocaine which is
kids that is the worst drug it really is
because you get a little honeymoon
period and then that quickly goes away
and then you're chasing that high and
you know it's not healthy and then you
know you're you're trying to at the end
of the night take the edge off you know
you're into that put the edge gotta put
the edge back on it
got off too much my drinking Jack
Daniels damn now I gotta take it off
again I put it on too much it's that was
I never touched it I got lucky you very
smart I would probably really enjoyed it
I think I would have really enjoyed it
yes probably why didn't I again at the
beginning yeah it's very much like a
relationship okay
good at the beginning you know I think
trails off yeah I always say because
resentment or is it time and
relationships are good spoiler alert
it's the beginning for a lot of them for
sure now when you put that book out is
it still in publication another great
question I'm finding so much about my
own life here I didn't know because the
comics incorrect was being redone
comments from my era like guys who grew
in general that when we were just
starting now there was a it was huge a
lot of guys pass it around a lot of guys
yeah hey you gotta get this book ya know
I mean and I tried to make it into a
movie there was many scripts written I
mean it's my own fault for not pushing
that through I guess but I thought at
the time it would really would have made
a a good movie but it's probably too
late now and well you definitely have to
change the names you know it's very hard
yeah I did in the script it's very yeah
it's very hard to depict stand-up comedy
in a movie in fact one of the original
impetus to write the book was that no
one was doing that well I remember that
movie came out with Tom Hanks remember
that hustling punchline okay and Tom
Hanks was good I mean Tom Hanks could
could have been a stand-up comic he did
it as good as you can passable passable
but they just never capture the whole
essence of it and also when you're
trying to have someone I see this on
Mazal know I haven't seen that yet some
show oh the one I think it's Jim Carrey
show on Showtime about oh I'm dying up
here
thank you yes and I like the show but
whenever you showing a stand-up comic
and you're in it's
acting you're acting as a stand-up and
then the audience has to laugh yeah
there's something about it that isn't it
just you can tell it's not real it's
like a boxing scene in a movie same
thing a little bit yeah
yeah Rocky right yeah but that's
sometimes purposely over-the-top this
just comes off as fake because one thing
we love about comedy is that laughter is
involuntary yeah it's in you can't as
any giant comedy star knows you can walk
out at a comedy club and you'll get the
biggest ovation in the world two minutes
later you can be dying because it's
involuntary has to thrilled to see you
but then if you don't say something
funny they can't they're not gonna laugh
it's also a very uniquely live thing
it's like you have to be right I always
say that like if you watch a special on
TV
you're really getting 60% of funny
you're right you have to be there live
you if you're there live you'll get a
hundred percent of it so not only that
not only you watching it not live right
because you've got a recording of it but
now it's also a fake recording so it's a
guy pretending to be on stage and an
audience pretending to be an audience
and the whole thing yeah disaster yeah
so maybe it's a blessing in this guy job
of capturing the marvelous mrs. Mazal
does of capturing like the early scene
in clubs like her going up drunk and
talking [ __ ] and then people telling her
like you could probably do comedy like
it seems chaotic and real but it gets a
little less realistic as time goes on
but you watch that show and yeah yeah I
like the first two seasons the third
season only I hope they're not losing me
here and it took place in the 50s yeah
yeah
[Applause]